nicole why did you decide to apply for
tv writing programs
i had been trying on my own for
many many years to break into the
business and i had been lucky enough to
have
some writers who were already in the
field read me and encourage me but
nobody was really able to help me get
representation or do any of that stuff
you have to do
to finally break through
and so the writing programs were sort of
the best option for somebody trying to
get their foot in the door
and i applied to all of them i had
varying success at all of them i had
no luck at warner brothers i have never
been able to move the needle in the
warner brothers writing program
i made the finals at disney twice but
then didn't make the last cut
uh and you know i had applied to all of
them multiple times and
when i finally applied to the cbs
writers program
and got in it was really a case of i i
was beating my head against the wall
right and i was just like how much more
of this can i do
and i had a backup plan in progress i
had started a cookie business and i was
like taking orders online
and i was baking in a kitchen that used
to be in pasadena but sadly is no longer
there where you could rent
a commercial kitchen space by the hour
so like i was getting up and running and
doing all this stuff with that
and i had a conversation with myself
where i was like well you're gonna
always write it's not like you're gonna
quit writing but i was just like i can't
keep doing this i can't keep
applying to these fellowships and all
those sorts of things and what happened
basically was i went to my day job
and my boss yelled at me for caring too
much about how i did my job
and it was just so antithetical to how i
had been brought up by my very like
military catholic black parents
to like do your best at everything and
always over perform and do all those
things and i couldn't make sense of it
and i came home and i had cried myself
to sleep basically because i was just
like well i don't want to do this either
like this is terrible
and i woke up in the morning and i
thought you know try one more time like
is there anything you can still apply to
just try
and for the first time
in the history of the cbs writers
program except for when the pandemic
happened
they had delayed the application period
by one month
and i had two days to get a script in
and because my mentors were always
making me write i had a script ready to
go
and i put it in the mail and i got it
postmarked and next thing i knew i was
in the program
wow
so many questions with that first off
just curious what was that script
it was a spec episode of the closer
which was one of my favorite shows and
you know it was funny because a lot of
people had said to me like i don't know
if you should expect that because nobody
in the business reads the you know
watches this show
and i was like i'm gonna write a show
that i know i can write just balls out
like with all the passion all the joy i
can put into it and i love this show and
so that's the script i'm gonna write
and i had multiple people tell me once
it got into the you know the writing
program circuit and people were reading
it
that they don't watch the show but they
loved the story and they had to see how
it ended
and so that's always my advice to young
writers now it's like write the spec
that you of a show you love whether you
think people watch it or not because
good writing leaps off the page
and i do think young writers should
still be writing specs it is my advice
to them
one just have one for a show you love
because there are show runners who will
not staff
staff writers unless they see a spec
it's not common anymore but there
there's a growing movement among
showrunners to get back to that because
writing a specs group of television is
literally the job you're trying to get
you have to write someone else's show
in their voice in the exact format that
they like
and you have to get as close to it as
you can
so
that's the job so why not practice it
before you get the job
were they telling you to write other
things that were quote unquote popular
at the time
there were definitely other shows that
were more popular i think a lot of
people were writing you know the walking
dead
there were there were lots of shows and
i
typically as a tv fan
will love one or two of the really
popular things but i tend to love more
bread and butter shows like
i was a huge castle fan i was a huge fan
of person of interest in elementary and
like those were the shows that i wanted
to spend my time on
and less so you know the walking dead or
mad men and because they just were not
my they were not the kind of shows i get
joy from
and so people were like well you have to
write you know you have to write a more
serious drama and i was like do i though
like i feel like i don't
and so i'm really glad i stuck to my
guns because it worked out
what most people tell young writers now
is to be writing pilots and they should
be absolutely be writing their own
original stories
but
a a really great pilot isn't proof to me
that you can write my tv show
so that's why i always tell people they
should still have a spec around for a
current show that's airing just in case
someone asks for it
and a show that they really care about
because that's going to show yes
i think especially because right when
what was happening when i broke in
was everyone was expecting the same
shows
so if you could stand out somehow by
having a show that they were not used to
reading
right away you were like oh well this is
a different show
this isn't the 17th madman spec i'm
getting this what is this close respect
and so it is another way to stand out if
you're not doing these the shows that
everybody else is doing
were you able to go back to that job and
give your two weeks
so interestingly what happened with that
job i
continued doing it while i was doing the
cvs program
because you know it's not a paid program
and then so i had to keep paying my
bills and
i also continued to do it during writers
on the verge which i did after the cbs
program
and that was about the time that i was
like you know what
even if i have to take a job
you know cleaning houses or doing
whatever
i can do hard work i can work as hard as
other people who are paying their bills
i can't do this job anymore
and i put my notice in and two weeks
later i got my first staff writing job
so i always tell people i feel like the
universe was like well she means it this
time
[Laughter]
so we better help her out
wow what a great story and the cookie
business the cookie business went away
because i was too busy uh writing
however the baking did not go away so my
writers rooms are always very happy they
get lots of cookies
everyone in my life likes to get baked
goods for christmas so you know it's it
the baking part still happens just not
the business part
how many tv writing programs can you
name
there is the abc disney fellowship and
some of them have tweaked their names
slightly before i say them all so trust
me when you look them up it might be
worded a little bit different but abc
disney's fellowship
nbc's uh
i
i can't remember what they're calling it
now but they they did reenact their
writing program so just look for nbc tv
writing program and you'll find it
uh the now viacom writers mentoring
program which is the cbs program now
there is um
oh goodness the warner brothers program
is still there
there have been fellowships and i'm not
as wired into these but i know for a
while um uh
sundance was doing one i believe that
was a like tv incubator for new writers
um
there have been other like uh
oh i'm going to forget the name of the
production company ron howard's company
imagine has done their own writing
program where they've encouraged writers
to submit and have done some stuff so
it's really if you if you go look up
writing programs there are a lot of
opportunities now that didn't exist
i'm currently a mentor in a newer one
it's called mentorship matters
we just finished our application period
on the 26th and we got 800 applications
so we'll you know our readers are going
through that process now of reading
everything and sort of narrowing the
field um but that one started uh some
wonderful people
um real tucker gianna sobel and carol
kirschner all got together during the
pandemic sort of post george floyd's
murder and decided like
what what can we do like we're full of
anger and the world is crazy what can we
do
and they came up with the idea for this
program where we give people who haven't
been assistants haven't had a chance
to access hollywood yet
the opportunity to be read and be
mentored and see if they can break
through
how many writers get into these programs
a year not just the ones that you
put in for but like all of them in
general you know it'd be hard to say i
mean they all the numbers vary like
the cbs program usually takes anywhere
from five to eight people i believe
um you know i think we had
eight people in my nbc class i think
disney usually takes ten
so it's sort of i mean mentorship
matters we had more than that because as
many mentors as we had because each
mentor got one
writer so we had
i want to say
35-ish mentors so we all had a mentee so
it really sort of depends on what the
program can accommodate
and so for mentorship matters you said
800 just for the the phrase it the first
year that it's we finished the first
year so this is going to be for year
number two starting in the fall
wow 800 and this is um globally
it's yeah i think it was
if i remember correctly anyone could
apply but you had to be able to be
in the u.s to do the program because
they there are like panels that have to
occur and there's staffing opportunities
part of what we do
in that program is use our network to
help our mentees so introducing them to
reps to
show runners to other writers that they
can connect with and you kind of need to
be
in the vicinity to do that even though
we have zoom now it's easier i think so
i do think there's a us requirement but
i can't remember
entirely
do you have to pay to be in the program
or do they pay you
most of the programs don't pay but you
do not have to pay to be in them they
are
investment programs that the networks
have in the studios have come up with to
try to to grow homegrown talent with an
angle on diversity
and inclusion so
the abc disney program has historically
been the only one that pays its writers
and they pay like i believe it's like 50
000 a year
while you're in it but it does mean and
you have a greater chance of staffing
because they can put you out to the
entire abc disney family right for
staffing opportunities but it does mean
you get paid that salary you're not
getting paid a staff writer salary
most of the other programs what they do
is the studio has money set aside so if
for instance when i got my job on
ironside the studio supplemented my
salary so it didn't come out of the show
budget and that's how they try to
encourage people to give writers like me
an opportunity and then if you prove
yourself you get to stay on regardless
and they'll you know you have to make
the showrunner be willing to pay for you
[Laughter]
i do think there's a movement now to
start adjusting that a little bit
because what we've been finding is that
showrunners
will use the freewriter not all some let
me make sure that's clear some
showrunners will use the freewriter for
as long as the studio will pay for them
and then not bring them back and so the
studios are now looking at how can they
make it
um an encouraging factor to keep the
writers going forward so they're looking
at how they can change that payment
system a little bit
to you know to encourage retention